>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> My name is Philip Kennicott,
I am the culture critic
of the Washington Post.
Since the very beginning of
the National Book Festival,
the Washington Post has been
a sponsor and will remain so
and I can tell you that one of the
great benefits of that is we get
to come down here and see that
there are in fact still people
who are passionate about books.
I have the pleasure today of
introducing author Bruce Feiler.
He has written books that take
both the author and the reader
on some extraordinary journeys,
whether that is Under The Big Top
to a year spent his life of a clown
or in one of his most renowned
and popular books, Walking the
Bible, where he explored one
of the most beautiful and
[inaudible] and inspiring
and conflicted landscapes
in the world.
He is also a journalist.
He writes the Family Matters column
for another newspaper called
The New York Times that appears
in the Sunday Style section.
Some of you, if you read the
Washing Post remember that he wrote
about a year ago for us on one of
the subjects that he has returned to
and that is the way in which Old
Testament figures play a recurring
role in our life.
He in that story he made
the case to why he believes
that Moses is the Patron
Saint of Washington.
His most recent book however is
very different and very personal.
It is a powerful book and it
is called, The Council of Dads:
My Daughters, My Illness and the Men
Who Could Be Me, and so I am going
to leave Bruce to talk
about that book,
please give him a warm welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning.
Thank you Philip and friends out--
who have been my classmate
in college.
It is great to be here.
I was here four years-- who was
here, I was here four years ago
and it is just amazing to see how
this festival has doubled in size,
how the rain has finally left.
I understand there's been
rain basically every year.
I am delighted to be here for the
many reasons you might imagine.
And in fact, I began my writing
life living not that far from here
in DuPont Circle almost 20
years ago, back in the day
where there was no Internet, no
cable, just me and Diane Rehm
in my-- yes, God bless Diane Rehm.
And I have to say it was one of the
great moments in my life when I was
on The Diane Rehm Show
for Walking the Bible
and to know how much she has
honored writers and words and to be
on that show and I have since
been on a couple of times.
It has been a highlight
of my professional life.
I grew up in Savannah, Georgia
and when I was four years old,
my parents moved to
a new neighborhood.
And this was actually in the sixties
and still today all the streets
in this neighborhood were named
after confederate war generals.
We lived on Robert E. Lee Boulevard.
And for my fifth birthday my parents
gave me an orange Schwinn Stingray
bicycle, okay, it had one of
those swooping banana seats
and those ape hanger handlebars
because it made the rider
look like an orangutan.
And I bet I will get a bigger--
who had, anybody remember the--
it turns out that two thirds of
Americans, I didn't know this,
had a Schwinn Stingray bicycle.
And one day I was exploring
our neighborhood and I decided
to take a kind of quick turnaround
in this major thoroughfare
that bisects our neighborhood,
when, wham!
I was hit by a passing Sedan.
My mangled bike flew in one
direction, my mangled body flew
in another, and I was lying across
the yellow line on the pavement
and one of our neighbors went
running over and she said, Andy,
Andy, how are you doing, using
the name of my older brother.
I am Bruce I said and
promptly passed out.
I broke my left femur that day.
It is the largest bone in your body
and spent the next two weeks in--
excuse me, in the next two
months in a wheelchair.
Actually, I was in a body cast first
that went from my chin to my knee
and then a steel bar went from
my right knee to my left leg.
So, I was in a wheelchair and
then I went on and live my life
and basically for most of my
life I never really thought
about my illness.
In fact, as you well know and as you
heard I made a living by walking,
by travelling around the world,
entering different cultures,
and writing about them.
Walking the Bible became a book
that touched people around the world
and ultimately became a television
series, and I was the walking guy
and as I said never
thought about my accident.
Until one day, two years ago, I
went to get a routine blood test
and an enzyme called the alkaline
phosphatase number was a little bit
high and my doctor
suggested I go get a scan,
which suggested there was some
sort of vague tumor in my left leg.
That scan led to another,
to an MRI, to an x-ray
and then one day I got
a call from my doctor,
"the tumor in your leg is not
consistent with a benign tumor."
I stopped walking and it took a
second from my mind to convert
that double negative into a
much more horrifying negative.
I had cancer and to think that
the tumor was in the same leg,
in the same bone, in the same
place in my body it seemed
like too much of a coincidence.
So, that afternoon I went home
and my then three-year-old identical
twin daughters came running
to meet me.
They had just turned three
as I said and they were in,
at this time of their life, they
were into all things, kind of pink
and purple, tutus and ballerinas
and mermaids and make up.
In fact, we called them
Pinkelicious and Purplelicious.
Although, I have to say
our favorite nickname came
from when they were born at
6:14 and 6:46 on April 15, 2005,
our otherwise grim doctor looked
at his watch and he was like, hum,
April 15th, tax day, early
filer and late filer.
So, okay, on this day Pinkelicious
and Purplelicious, they came running
in to meet me and they were doing
this dance they had just made
up when they turned three and
they went go faster and faster
and then they tumbled to the ground.
And I looked at them and I crumbled.
I kept imagining all the walks
I might not take with them,
the ballet recitals I might not see,
the boyfriends I might not scowl at,
the aisles I might not walk down.
Would they wonder who I was,
I thought, would they yearn
for my approval, my love, my voice.
Three days later I woke with an idea
of how I might give them that voice.
I would reach out to six men from
all parts of my life and ask them
to be present in the
lives of my daughters.
And I said to myself that
I would call this group
of men the Council of Dads.
Now, as soon as I had this
idea I decided I was not going
to tell my wife.
Okay, she is a very upbeat person,
she is got a big smile, and big eyes
and big hair, although, she
told me recently I can't say
that she has big hair because people
will think that she is from Texas.
So, apparently like it is okay
to marry a boy from Georgia,
but not to have hair from Texas.
In fact, if she were here which
she can't be today because she is
in Boston, if she were here
she would tell that story
that when we got married and
how seven years ago, we in,
and we got married in Savannah,
my hometown and we went
to get the license, you know the
marriage certificate, whatever,
the marriage license that
is what it is called,
and there were three
questions on the questionnaire,
the third of which
was, are you related.
So, she was horrified by this, but
I was like, you know if you say yes,
you get to skip the one
month waiting period
because you already get there
and you already know each other
and you can jump to the
front of the line, anyway.
Okay so, I decided I wasn't going to
tell her about the Council of Dads,
right, we should happy our
way, this is America, right,
we are just happy our
way through a problem,
but the next day I couldn't
control myself, I told her
and she loved the idea,
but she instantly started
rejecting my nominees.
So, she said, well, I
would love him, but,
you know I would never
ask him for advice.
So, it turned out that
starting a Council
of Dads was a very
efficient way to find
out what my wife really
thought of my friends.
So, we decided that we needed a
set of rules and so we made or came
up with a group of rules.
The first one was no
family, only friends.
We figured our family
would already be there
and then the second was only
men because we were trying
to fill the Dads space, and then
the third was basically a Dad
for every side.
We kind of went through different
parts of my personality and kind
of pick a Dad that
represented each one.
And then, I actually had
written a letter to these Dads,
but rather than mail it
I decided to sit down
and read it to them in person.
I mean, Linda joked that it was
like having six different
marriage proposals, right,
I sort of friend-married
each of these guys.
So, the first of these
was Jeff Shumlin.
Now, Jeff grew up in Vermont and
he runs a student travel company
and he led this tour, he kind
of taught me how to travel
when I graduated from high school.
And on that first day, we were in
Holland in a youth hostel behind
and built in an old castle.
And I sneaked out and then
Jeff came and sat beside me
and there was this, there was a
moat, a fence, and a field of cows.
And Jeff leaned over and he said,
so, have you ever been cow-tipping.
I was like, cow-tipping?
He said, yes, cows sleep standing
up, so if you approach them
from behind you can push them
over and they go thud in the mud.
So, before I had the chance to
figure out whether this was true,
we had jumped the moat,
we had scaled the fence
and we were tiptoeing
through the dung
and approaching some
poor dozing cow.
So, Jeff went back to Vermont and
this kind of trip taught me how
to travel and he went
back to Vermont,
took over this travel company that
his parents started and spent part
of everyday writing around on
a tractor and shoveling manure,
and part you know, leading
students on trips around the world.
And this is really what Linda and
I wired him to convey to our girls,
what it means to come from
a place, but also to be open
to the rest of the world.
Jeff would teach them how to travel.
So, a few weeks after my
diagnosis, we popped in my car,
we drove the kids to up to Vermont.
Jeff and I went and sat in an apple
orchard and I read him this letter,
will you help me their Dad.
And I got to the end, he
was crying and I was crying
and he looked at me
and he said, yes.
I was like, yes?
I had kind of forgotten there
was this question at the heart
of the letter and it-- first,
it never occurred to me
that anybody would turn me down,
although, I keep getting asked
that question repeatedly.
So then, I asked Jeff a question,
I said, so what is the one piece
of advice you would
give to my girls?
And his answer was so mind
blowing and I ended up asking this
of all the Dads in time and
it is really what compelled me
to write this book, The Council
of Dads, which was to gather all
of this life advice into one place.
And so, in Jeff's case,
his advice was,
he wanted to teach my
girls how to travel.
He said I want to teach them
to be a traveler not a tourist.
So, get off the beaten
path, get off that bus,
seek out what is different,
approach the cow.
So, it's ten years from
now, I said in our--
my girls are about to
take their first trip,
what advice would you give them?
He said, I would tell your
girls to approach this trip
as a young child might
approach a mud puddle.
You can bend over and look at
your reflection on the water
and maybe make a small ripple or
you can jump in and thrash around
and see what it feels
like, what it smells like.
As he was talking he had
that glint in his eye
that I first saw behind
that youth hostel.
The glint that says,
let's go cow-tipping,
even though we didn't tip the cow,
even though no one tips the cow,
even though cows don't
sleep standing up.
And just that I want to see
you back here girls at the end
of this experience covered in mud.
Two weeks after my
diagnosis of biopsy-confirmed,
I have a 7-inch osteosarcoma
in my left femur,
600 Americans get an osteosarcoma
every year, 85-percent are under 21,
only 100 adults a year
get this disease.
Twenty years ago, doctors would
have cut off my leg and hoped
and there was a 15-percent
survival rate, but they determined
that one cocktail of
chemo could be effective
and I went and got that cocktail.
And I got what doctors
call a chemo sandwich,
which I don't recommend you get
from the-- up the pavilion here,
which was four months of chemo
followed by a 15-hour surgery
in which my surgeon Dr. John
Healey removed my left femur
and replaced it with titanium,
took my fibula from my calf
and relocated it to
my thigh and then took
out a third of my quadriceps muscle.
A surgery so rare, only two
people have survived it before me
and my reward for surviving
it was to go back
for four more months of chemo.
It was as we called it around
our house, the lost year
and we were worried
from the beginning
about how our girls might react.
And I have to say there were--
in the beginning there was some
nightmares, one of them would get
up in the middle of the night and
there was some awkward moments.
One night, I had a nightmare that
I was walking through my house
and I sat at my desk and saw photos
of someone else's children sitting
on my desk, but by
the end I came to see
that maybe perhaps it made
our daughters an ounce more
compassionate and a
dose more caring.
They would run to embrace the
girl with an amputated leg
at the playground, they would
notice the girl with the rabbit
with the crunches in the back of
a children's book illustration.
And my daughter Tybee had a one,
great line one day, she said, Daddy,
I think she began to realize how
valuable her parents were, she said,
Daddy, I have so much
love in my body for you,
I can't stop giving
you hugs and kisses.
And when I have no more
love left, I just drink milk
because that is where
love comes from.
And one night, my daughter Eden came
to my side of the bed and as I got
up and went to put her back to
sleep, she reached for my crutches
and if I could cling to one memory
from my lost year it would be me
and my daughter walking down
the darkened hallway at four
in the morning with five little
fingers grasping the spongy handle
underneath my hand.
I didn't need the crutch anymore
at that time, I was walking on air.
One interesting thing about
The Council of Dads was
that it forced me to sit
down with my closest friends
and tell them what they
meant to me and I began
to realize how rare
that is in this culture.
If you think about it we all have
our work and we have our family,
but somehow friends get pushed
aside because it is almost something
that conspires against
friendship in our life today.
And one thing the Council of Dads
and as I have seen our people
making this around the country,
around the world, the Council of
Moms that is emerging out of this is
that this has proven to be a
bridge that invites our friends
into the heart of our lives.
And the other thing I
learned is how much the role
of men has changed over time.
I mean, if I think about my
father and my grandfather,
both of them I write about in my
book, there was something about them
that they were not so communicative.
The men in my council, we talk
about our friends, our feelings,
our fears, even our weight.
Linda kept saying in these
conversations with these Dads,
she is like, it is
exactly what the Moms talk
about at school drop off every day.
And to me, no one embodies
this modern malehood more
than David Black.
David, I first met David, he is
my literary agent, I first met him
in his office in Manhattan and I
should say, he is five foot three
and a half on a good day
standing erect in cowboy boots,
and he took one look at my
six foot two body and said,
if I were your height,
I'd be in the NBA.
Self delusion is a wonderful thing,
it is even better in an agent.
So, David, he embodies kind
of modern manhood, you know,
on the man front, he kind of say
this on the, for the posterity
of the Library of Congress, he
answers the phone, yo, motherfucker.
He gives obscure speeches on
bottles of wines nobody cares about
and on his 50th birthday, he bought
himself a convertible sports car.
But actually, like a lot of men,
he is impatient he
bought it on his 49th.
But on the modern man
front, he hugs, he bakes,
he leaves work early
to coach little league.
Someone asked me if David cried when
I invited him to be in the council
of Dads, I was like, David cries
when you invite him for a walk.
So, David is a literary agent which
means he is a broker of dreams
in a world where most dreams don't
come true, but he is very good
at handling both the
aspirations and the setbacks
and this is what we wanted him
to teach our girls, how to dream.
So, I said to him, so, what is the
most valuable thing you can teach
a dreamer?
He said a belief in themselves.
I said, okay, that is fine, but when
I met you, I might have had belief
in myself, but I was in a wall.
I had no path after writing three
books to some degree of success.
He said, well, I don't see the
wall and I am telling you the same.
Of course you may encounter a wall
from time to time, but I am going
to show you how to get over it
around it, under it, or through it,
but whatever you do, don't succumb
to it, don't give in to the wall.
So, it is 15 years from now, I
said one of my daughters pops down
and she says, I have a dream, I want
to write a book or open a restaurant
or run a marathon,
what do you tell her?
He said, I will tell her let's
make the awesome mundane,
to make an outline for the book, or
a business plan for the restaurant,
a route to the top of the mountain.
And if that dream should fail
I said, then I will tell her,
let's find a dream that can work.
It may not be the first
dream or the second dream,
it is a dream nonetheless.
Because anybody can dream
an impossible dream,
but only a few find a
dream that is possible
and those are the ones
that are happy.
My house is not far from the
Brooklyn Bridge and during the year
and a half that I was on crutches
it became a sort of symbol to me.
And one day, I said to my girls,
come on, let's take a walk
across the Brooklyn Bridge.
So, we set out, the girls
were-- Linda was beside me,
I was on crutches, my
girls were doing this kind
of rock star poses they
had learned when they,
that may have looked
like Mick Jagger.
And walking, because walking is one
of the first things I lost during
that year I spent a lot
of time thinking about it.
And if you do think about it,
walking is really the one thing
that most distinguishes
us from our ancestors,
and yet for the 4 million years
that humans have walked upright,
the act is essentially unchanged.
It is really, the act
is very simple,
but very hard because every step as
my physical therapist likes to say,
is a tragedy waiting to happen.
You almost tumble with one leg
and then you catch
yourself with the other.
But the cheap act of going
slow is that you begin
to develop a community
along the way.
So, you hurry, you get where you
are going, but you get there alone.
You go slow, you get there, but
you get there with this community
that you have developed
along the way.
At the risk of admission,
I was never nicer
than when I was on crutches.
Two hundred years ago in Paris, a
new type of pedestrian appeared.
He was called a Flaneur, one who
ambles the arcades and for these men
of leisure they showed off that they
were men of status by taking turtles
for walks and letting
the reptile set the pace.
And I love this ode to slow-moving.
It's become a piece of advice for
my girls, take a walk with a turtle.
Behold the world in pause.
And that sense of slowing down,
of pausing may be the single
biggest lesson I learned.
The Liberty Bell has a quote
from Moses on its side,
"Proclaim liberty throughout
the land
and to all the inhabitants thereof."
And that comes from a passage in
Leviticus in which we are told
that every seven years, the
land is supposed to lay fallow
and every seven sets of seven years,
the land gets an extra year of rest
and that 50th year is
called the jubilee year.
It is actually the origin
of the term jubilee.
And during that year, we
are supposed to be reunited
with the ones we love and
though I am still short of 50
that perfectly captures
my experience.
My lost year was my jubilee year.
By laying fallow, I was
surrounded with the ones I love
and I planted the seeds
for a healthier future.
On the one year diagnosis of my
cancer, I went to see my doctor,
Dr. John Healey, and by the way,
Healey, great name for a doctor.
He is the president of
the International Society
of Limb Salvage, which is like
the least euphemistic name I have
ever heard.
And he also pauses.
He speaks like three words a minute;
those of you who may
have seen the special
that Sanjay Gupta did on my family.
I mean, he spoke faster and not
that I have never heard him speak.
So, I said to him, I said, doctor,
if my girls come to you one day
and say, what should we
learn from our Daddy's story,
what would you tell them.
And he paused about as long as
ever anyone pause and he said,
I would tell my daughters
what I have learned
and that is everybody dies,
but not everybody lives.
I want you to live.
I wrote a letter to my daughters.
It appears at the end
of the Council of Dads
and I listed all the
wisdom I heard from my Dads.
You have heard a couple here
today, there are many more,
approach the cow, live the
questions, pack your flip-flops,
don't see the wall,
live the questions--
did I say that one,
harvest the miracles.
And when I looked at this
I realized, you know what,
this is sort of a psalm book of
living for my girls and that is
when I realized, it was intended
for them, but maybe, we are the ones
who need them, and
that is the secret
at the heart of the Council of Dads.
Linda and I did it for our
girls, but it changed us and so,
I stand here today as you have
seen recovered from my journey
and walking without crutches or a
cane for the first time in two years
and I leave you with
this message-- thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> May you find a wall to
get over, around, or through.
May you find a mud puddle to jump
in one day and one of these days,
grab a friend, grab a turtle,
and take a long slow walk.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Labeled Water at the
National Mall, okay.
So, I would be happy to answer.
We have two microphones, I
am sure you know the drill.
I would be happy to answer whatever
questions you might have about this
or Walking the Bible,
or the-- anything else?
Okay, someone is going to come
to me-- here we go, here we go,
excellent, somebody, run, I
can't run, so you run for me.
Yeah?
>> I just, I just wondered
if you ever thought
about doing something
like The Last Lecture.
>> The-- I do do a lot of lecturing.
I'm not sure what you mean by
something like The Last lecture,
you mean, like a-- there
is actually if you go to--
>> It is a book that--
>> I know the book, yeah, David
Black, I'm sure represented it.
You know, in fact David
Black, my agent,
oddly represented both Tuesdays
with Morrie and The Last Lecture
and now the Council of Dads,
and I do, do a lot of talking.
In fact, if you go to
councilofdads.com you can see,
you can get or download
a starter kit
for people who are starting these.
And so, I do do a fair bit of
talking about this at medical groups
and synagogues and
universities and places like that.
Let's see over here.
Yes, ma'am?
>> Hi, what is your next project?
>> The question is,
what is my next project.
There is-- I have a number of
things that are in the works.
As you heard, Philip
mentioned earlier,
I now write a column
called Family Matters
in the Sunday New York Times,
the Sunday Style section.
So, as you are on your way
to the wedding announcements,
that is what you are after,
we all know, you know,
the sports section for women.
I hope to stop you for a
few minutes on page two.
I am doing a-- I'm actually
beginning to write a book
about family life in America today.
I am actually working on another
television series in the wake
of Walking the Bible with
PBS about pilgrimage.
And I will also say, I am
not exactly involved in this,
but I am somewhat involved and
that is the Council of Dads is now
or has been bought by Fox
Broadcasting and it is
in development with a guy
named called Peter Tolan
who did Larry Sanders and Rescue
Me and Murphy Brown to turn--
I'm not making this up,
to turn into a sitcom.
And I have to say in his version,
I have actually never said this,
I don't know how this will
go over, but in his version,
he is actually doing it in
the original conception.
So, there is actually a dead dad
as I call it, there is a widow
and there is a Council of
Dads because everybody wants
to know what happened
to the council, and so,
my book doesn't go
there unfortunately.
So, he is going there,
he is going to--
so, as I said, the
sitcom about my death.
Anyway, so that is-- they
have asked me to con--
you know they pay me with
this consulting deals,
so I don't know what exactly
I was supposed to offer,
but that is another
thing that is going on.
Yes sir?
>> In Walking the Bible, you
met some incredible scholars.
>> Yeah.
>> And wise people and I wonder if
you are keeping in touch with any
of them and if you have any advice
for the diplomats in
the city right now.
>> The question was about
Walking the Bible and yes,
I met a lot of great people.
Avner Goren who is the archeologist,
who I travel with both in the book
and the television, so we are
still very close, actually he was
at our home earlier this summer.
Father, to those of you
who have read the book,
Father Justin who is
the Texas monk who lives
at St. Catherine has now
become the chief librarian.
And I actually list his
email address in the book
because there is a Burning
Bush there in St. Catherine's
and there is a very memorable scene
in the book when I first arrived
at St. Catherine which
is in the Sinai,
which is where the monk say
the original Mount Sinai was
and there is a bush.
It is actually a rare
raspberry bramble
that the monk say is
the actual Burning Bush
where Moses saw the Face of
God and right next to this bush
which is kind of is a big
kind of weeping willow kind
of thing is a fire extinguisher.
And the first time I saw it,
I thought is this an eye sore
and then I realized the unintended--
is this in case the Burning Bush
catches on fire and if it does catch
on fire, do I look for the Face
of God or do I put the fire out.
And years later when we
went to make the TV show,
we filmed a little sequence with
me and the fire extinguisher
and we sent it back to L.A. to
be edited and the editors took
out the fire extinguisher.
And when the draft came out,
I was like, why did you take
out the fire extinguisher,
they said, you made that up.
That's just a really bad
joke and you made that up.
I was like no, no, no, I
didn't make that up at all.
So, I am still in touch with Father
Justin and a lot of those people.
And that journey does continue
in the book, Where God Was Born,
which was what I talked about
the last time I was here
and I was just actually in for those
of you who have come in designing,
we actually have tons of copies
of Abraham, Walking the Bible,
Where God Was Born,
America's Prophets,
they have all that stuff here.
Yes sir.
>> I am just curious
if the travel program
from Vermont was the experiment
in International Living and if so,
do you have a brief commercial for
it or describe the actual program.
>> The experiment for
International Living is one
out of Brattleboro, Vermont.
Actually, I will be in
Brattleboro a week from today
at the Brattleboro
Literary Festival.
This has come out-- is one of Putney
in Vermont is called
Putney Student Travel.
So, it is a smaller family
run operation that has been
in the same family for 50
years and it is fantastic.
Go Putney.com I would
give it an ad too,
but it is the same
spirit as the experiment.
Yes sir, we got-- they are
giving me a minute here.
>> Sure, any suggestion for
somebody with some similar ideas
to start writing their own book.
>> Well, I am a big believer in,
you know, for aspiring writers
that the most important
thing is to write.
I find in talking to people that
there are a lot of aspiring writers
who are a lot better at aspiring
than they are at writing.
When I was in college I went to
see William Baldwin speak at Yale
and he said, you want to be a
writer kid, you know, get a chair,
get a table, get a piece of paper
and get a pen and start writing.
I actually think that, you know,
when I went to Japan 20 years ago
and started writing letters
home on crankily airmail paper,
I think that the barriers to entry
were actually a lot higher then,
so I think we have to be seen
now with blogging, with, I mean,
there's any newspapers,
The Washington Post not least among
them having written three pieces
free for them in the last
month, that they will--
a lot of people will
take free content.
And so, I think that the most
important thing is to get published
and it can be a church newsletter,
it can be a blog, it can be a letter
that gets circulated to
friends because I think
that the most important thing is to
get into the active communication
and so, that you start
showing your writing.
I think journaling is fine and has
had a lot of value to me and lots
of people over the years, but
ultimately, I think writing is
about communication and I was
in the media earlier saying
what does it mean to you to come
to the National Book Festival
and I said, it means to me
to be reminded ultimately that
this is about communication,
to have writers in touch with
readers, having feedback,
that is what it is about.
So, I am delighted to be here to
share the story with all of you.
If you want to email me, you
can go to brucefeiler.com.
I answer every email that
comes and happy reading.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.